[Music]
smart cars and Home Appliances machines
that help cities factories and Farms
work collected objects make up the
internet of things and are generating
ever more data
[Music]
why is data important
access to data is key to Innovation but
lots of data remains untapped or
controlled by Tech Giants
the European Parliament wants a fairer
deal for smaller businesses
sounds great but how
with a law to open up access to
non-personal data and Empower new
players the data act will let companies
and the public sector deliver better
products and services
what about my privacy
EU rules will continue to protect your
personal information
what can citizens and businesses expect
new products developed in the EU smarter
Greener cities farms and factories
cheaper services and repairs better
management of emergencies safeguards on
how data is shared
foreign
[Music]